Si l'on en croit les astrophysiciens,
notre univers serait composé à plus de 80% d'une matière inconnue
qu'on a jamais directement observé
et dont la nature et les propriétés nous échappent complétement,
la matière noire.
Mais si on ne l'a jamais observée ni détectée, cette matière noire
comment on fait pour être sur qu'elle existe ?
Les premiers indices concernant la matière noire ont déjà plus de 80 ans.
En 1933, un astronome Suisse, Fritz Zwicky,
observe ce que l'on appelle l'amas de Coma
qui est un groupe de galaxies
situé à plus de 300 millions d'années lumières de nous.
Zwicky constate que les galaxies s'y déplacent comme si
L'amas contenait beaucoup plus de matière
que ce qu'on était capable de l'estimer en l'observant.
Zwicky suggère alors qu'il y aurait dans l'amas
une grande quantité de matière, qu'il qualifie de sombre,
qui n'émettrait pas de lumière et qui expliquerait ce mouvement anormal des galaxies
Alors à première vue, il n'y a pas de quoi s'étonner qu'il y ait de la matière qui n'émette pas de lumière
Après tout, il y en a plein autour de nous: les planètes, les astéroïdes, les lunes, etc.
Oui, sauf que tout ça, ça ne pèse rien en comparaison des étoiles
Par exemple, Jupiter, la plus grosse planète du système solaire
ne pèse qu'un millième de la masse du soleil
Donc pour expliquer la matière noire, il faut trouver une autre explication que les planètes
Mais avant d'aller plus loin, il faut qu'on comprenne mieux
en quoi étudier le mouvement de corps
Comme des galaxies ou des étoiles
Permet de faire des estimations de masse.
Pour ça, on va prendre l'exemple du système solaire.
Je vous ai mis ici les 8 planètes que vous connaissez bien et Pluton en bonus.
Avec leurs vitesses moyennes respectives
Vous remarquez un truc ?
Plus les planètes sont éloignées du soleil.
Plus leur vitesse est faible.
En fait tout ça est parfaitement logique.
Et cela se calcule très bien.
Grâce à la loi de la gravitation universelle de Newton.
On peut directement relier la vitesse d'une planète à sa distance au soleil.
Pour les férus de détails, on écrit simplement que la force centrifuge est égale à la force de gravité.
Et on sort que la vitesse est inversement proportionnelle à la racine carrée de la distance.
Et cette formule colle parfaitement à ce que l'on observe.
Mais surtout, on voit qu'elle fait apparaitre la masse du soleil.
Ce qui veut dire, qu'en connaissant la vitesse et la distance des planètes
On peut déduire la masse du soleil.
Zwicky en faisant un calcul de ce genre
Mais adapté à l'échelle d'un amas de galaxies
trouve pour l'amas de Coma une masse totalement incompatible avec la quantité d'étoiles qu'on pouvait y observer.
et c'est comme ça que Zwicky déduit qu'il manque de la masse, et qu'elle doit
provenir d'une hypothétique matière
noire.
Toute cette histoire de masse manquante et de matière noire est restée une
curiosité pendant quelques décennies.
Mais à la fin des années 70, une astronome américaine, Vera Rubin, enfonce définitivement le clou.
En utilisant des télescopes évidemment
plus puissants que ceux de Zwicky
Vera Rubin réalise des observations directement au sein des galaxies
Il faut savoir qu'une galaxie a généralement la forme d'un disque
aplati, éventuellement en spirale,
et que toutes les étoiles tournent autour
du centre un peu comme les planètes autour du soleil.
Et comme pour le système solaire, on
s'attend donc à ce que les étoiles de la périphérie
se déplacent moins vite que celles du
centre
Vera Rubin trace pour plusieurs
galaxies ce qu'on appelle leur courbe de rotation,
c'est-à-dire un graphique qui montre la
vitesse des étoiles en fonction de
leur distance au centre de la galaxie
et elle observe que toutes les courbes se
comportent de la même manière
et notamment que la vitesse des étoiles
finit par stagner au fur et à mesure qu'on s'éloigne du centre,
au lieu de diminuer comme on aurait pu
s'y attendre.
Ces observations remarquables apportent la
preuve indiscutable qu'au sein même des galaxies,
on a un problème de masse manquante.
et on commence alors sérieusement à parler de matière noire.
Alors petite remarque en passant, ces observations qui sont déterminantes
pour la physique moderne datent d'il y a
plus de 40 ans
et on n'a toujours pas jugé bon de
filer le prix nobel à Vera Rubin...
enfin ça c'est ce que j'avais mis dans
mon script que j'ai écrit mi-décembre
mais malheureusement, Vera Rubin est
décédée le 25 décembre 2016,
sans avoir le Nobel, donc.
Alors depuis les travaux de Vera Rubin, on
a beaucoup reproduit et affiné les mesures
des courbes de rotation.
On est même capables de le faire pour
notre propre galaxie, la voie lactée.
Ces courbes nous permettent de savoir
d'une part que la masse des galaxies
serait composée aux quatre cinquièmes de
matière noire,
et en plus elle nous permet d'estimer
la manière dont cette matière
noire est répartie dans les galaxies.
La forme des coubes de rotation nous
apprend qu'en plus de la matière classique,
les étoiles, le gaz,
qui se répartissent généralement en un disque aplati,
existerait un immense halo sphérique de
matière noire, qui s'étendrait même
au-delà de la zone de la matière lumineuse.
Ok, mais si elle est là cette matière
noire, elle est faite de quoi?
L'hypothèse qui paraît la plus
naturelle pour expliquer la présence de la matière noire,
c'est d'imaginer qu'il s'agirait d'astres
qui n'émettraient pas de lumière
mais qui seraient pas suffisamment denses pour apporter beaucoup de masses
sans qu'on les voit trop.
On peut penser notamment à des trous noirs
à des naines brunes qui sont des
étoiles qui n'ont pas vraiment réussi à s'allumer
ou encore à des étoiles à neutrons
qui sont des cadavres d'étoiles et
dont la densité peut-être cent mille milliards de fois celle des planètes ou des étoiles classiques
tous ces objets on les regroupe sous
l'acronyme des MACHOs
ça veut dire Massive Compact Halo Object
Si cette hypothèse est la bonne, cette
matière noire n'aurait rien de fondamentalement mystérieux
parce qu'elle serait composée des particules classiques dont on a l'habitude
hein, des atomes, des protons,  des neutrons qu'on regroupe sous le terme générique de Baryons.
Donc dans ce cas là, on parlerait de matière noire baryonique.
Cette hypothèse peut paraitre séduisante mais dans les années 80, un physicien Israélien
Mordehai Milgrom, propose une explication assez différente au problème de la masse manquante.
Il se dit que si la courbe de rotation des galaxies n'est pas ce qu'elle devrait être,
c'est pas forcement parce qu’il y a de la matière mystérieuse qu'on a pas réussi à observer
mais peut être tout simplement parce que les lois de la gravité sont différentes de ce qu'on s'imagine.
Il y a un précédent assez amusant à ce débat
dans le système solaire lui même.
Au 19e siècle, on avait remarqué que la planète Uranus ne se déplaçait pas comme le prévoyait les lois de Newton.
Certains étaient convaincus que c'était à cause de la présence d'une autre planète qu'on arrivait pas encore à voir.
Et grâce à ses calculs, l'astronome français Urbain Le Verrier a pu prouver la présence et calculer la position de cette planète mystérieuse
qui a ensuite été observée directement et qu'on appelle Neptune.
On avait un problème dans une trajectoire et la réponse était un corps massif qu'on avait pas encore vu.
Inversement, au début du 20e siècle, on cherchait à expliquer certaines anomalies de l'orbite de Mercure
et grâce aux travaux d'Einstein,
on comprit que ce n'était pas un problème de masse manquante ou de planète qu'on aurait pas encore découverte
mais que c'était parce que les lois de la gravité étaient différentes de celle de Newton
quand les champs gravitationnels deviennent très intenses. C'est la théorie de la Relativité Générale.
On avait un problème de trajectoire, mais cette fois, il fallait changer les lois de la gravité.
Et du coup, en 1983, Milgrom se dit que c'est peut être la même chose
peut être qu'il y a pas du tout de matière noire à découvrir mais simplement les lois de la gravité sont différentes de celle de Newton
mais cette fois, contrairement à la relativité générale, quand le champ gravitationnel devient très, très faible.
Il faut bien voir que pour une étoile située en périphérie d'une galaxie,
le champ gravitationnel exercé par la masse du reste de la galaxie est très faible,
hein, du genre, 1 milliard de fois plus faible que ce que nous on a, à la surface de la Terre.
Et on a jamais pu tester par des expériences les lois de la gravité dans des champs aussi faibles
donc on pourrait effectivement imaginer qu'elles soient différentes de la loi de Newton.
Milgom propose en particulier la modification suivante :
en dessous d'un certain seuil, la force de gravité ne diminuerait plus comme le carré de la distance
hein, en 1 sur R carré
mais en 1 sur R. On appelle ça la théorie MOND, c'est pour MOdified Newtonian Dynamics
Une des beautés de la théorie monde,
c'est qu'elle colle parfaitement avec l'idée de courbes de rotation des galaxies qui deviennent plates
parce que si l'accélération gravitationnelle finit par diminuer en 1 sur R
et bien il est normal que la vitesse de rotation devienne constante quand on s'éloigne suffisamment.
Séduisant, non ? Avec la théorie MOND, plus aucun problème de masse manquante ou de matière noire
oui sauf qu'il y a quand même plusieurs trucs qui clochent...
Le premier, c'est que dans certaines régions,
on observe une répartition qui est clairement différente pour la matière ordinaire et pour la matière noire.
C'est, par exemple, ce qu'il y a dans ce qu'on appelle l'amas du Boulet.
Il s'agit d'un amas de galaxies qui est le résultat de la collision de deux amas précédents
et pour lequel les observations montrent une répartition bien différente pour la matière noire et la matière lumineuse.
Ce qui ne colle pas du tout avec la théorie MOND.
Très récemment, en août 2016, on a même observé une galaxie, Dragonfly 44, qui serait composée à plus de 99 % de matière noire.
Ce qui là aussi ne colle pas tellement avec l'idée de la théorie MOND, d'une simple modification des lois de la gravité.
Mais on a d'autres indices qui pointent vers une nature encore plus étrange pour la matière noire
et qui nous viennent de la manière dont l'univers s'est formé.
Le Big Bang a eu lieu il y a 13,8 milliard d'années
et la meilleure preuve que l'on ait de cette période très dense et très chaude de l'histoire de l'univers
c'est ce qu'on appelle le rayonnement cosmologique, aussi appelé rayonnement fossile.
Une des particularités de ce rayonnement c'est que, quelque soit la direction dans laquelle on regarde,
il est exactement le même...
...enfin, pas tout à fait exactement.
Il fluctue très légèrement d'une direction à l'autre.
Un jour, je vous ferai une vidéo spécifique sur le thème des fluctuations du rayonnement cosmologique
et ce qui faut savoir pour l'instant, c'est qu'en analysant ces fluctuations
on peut tracer une courbe, le spectre de puissances des fluctuations angulaire
dont la forme nous apporte une foule de détails sur la composition de l'univers.
La position du premier pic, que vous voyez ici, nous renseigne sur la quantité totale de matière présente dans l'univers et donc sur la courbure de l'univers,
tandis que la taille des pics suivants permet spécifiquement de distinguer la matière ordinaire
de celle qui n'interagit pas avec le rayonnement électromagnétique.
Si la matière noire était de la matière normale, baryonique, comme des atomes, des protons ou des neutrons.
Le premier pic serait plus haut et les pics suivants plus bas.
Le fait que la taille des pics soit celle ci trahit la présence de matière noire non baryonique
et permet même d'en estimer la proportion, environ 80 %.
Cette observation, elle est vraiment très importante parce qu'elle nous montre que la matière noire ne peut pas être simplement de la matière ordinaire
qui se serait retrouvée condensée dans des trous noirs ou des étoiles à neutrons
Il s'agit d'un type de matière qui n'interagit pas avec les ondes électromagnétiques, quelque chose de vraiment différent.
Ces conclusions, on les retrouve aussi dans les scénarios qui simulent la manière dont les hétérogénéités initiales de l'univers
au moment du big bang ont fini par donner naissance aux amas de galaxies.
En bref, ces observations cosmologiques disqualifient la théorie MOND mais aussi les MACHOs, les objets compacts baryoniques.
Il faut chercher autre chose de vraiment plus exotique.
La piste qui est privilégiée à l'heure actuelle pour expliquer cette matière noire, c'est celle des WIMP
les Weakly Interacting Massive Particles,
des particules massives interagissant faiblement.
Alors alerte au jeu de mots, hein, wimp en anglais, ça veut dire mauviette, c'est pour contraster avec les MACHOs.
Mais ça pourrait être quoi ces particules mystérieuses et bah.... rien de ce qu'on connait déjà.
On a pensé un temps aux neutrinos, on sait aujourd'hui qu'ils ont une masse mais celle-ci est bien trop faible pour expliquer toute la matière noire.
Beaucoup ont pensé à des particules dites supersymétriques
alors la supersymétrie, c'est une théorie qui est une extension de la physique des particules classique
et qui prévoit tout un tas de nouvelles particules,
la supersymétrie est assez populaire parce qu'elle est notamment indispensable à la théorie des cordes.
Bon, le problème, c'est qu'au LHC, on a jamais pu observer la moindre particule supersymétrique
et il y a beaucoup de personnes qui commencent à sérieusement douter de leur existence.
Autre théorie alternative, des particules qu'on appelle les Axions,
ce sont des particules qu'on a jamais détectés
mais qui pourraient expliquer certaines symétries un peu inattendues de la force nucléaire forte.
Aujourd'hui, il existe un certain nombre d'expériences en cours ou planifiées pour détecter ces différents candidats de particules WIMP,
que ça soit en les détectant directement, soit en détectant le produit de leur annihilation.
Mais bon, à ce jour, on a eu aucun résultat. Et si la matière noire n'était qu'une impasse ?
Si finalement, l'approche MOND était la bonne, pas forcément dans sa forme actuelle,
mais du moins dans l'idée d'essayer de modifier les lois de la gravité plutôt que de chercher une hypothétique matière noire qui n'arrête pas de se dérober à nous.
Ce débat a été récemment relancé par deux publications.
La première, en août 2016, qui a montré, une nouvelle fois, sur un groupe de 153 galaxies, une extraordinaire similarité dans la forme des courbes de rotation
exactement comme le prévoirait la théorie MOND.
La seconde publication, on la doit à Erik Verlinde,
un physicien théoricien néerlandais qui est assez célèbre pour ces travaux en théorie des cordes.
Depuis quelques années, Verlinde travaille à une approche radicalement différente du problème de la gravité
dans laquelle il considère que la gravité est une force d'origine entropique.
Alors je ne vais pas vous décrire en détail son approche, hein, j'avais écrit un billet de blog sur le sujet, il y a quelques années
donc pour ceux que ça intéresse, je mettrais le lien dans la description.
Toujours est-il que récemment, Verlinde a suggéré que son approche permettait de retrouver les équations de la théorie MOND
tout en en résolvant certains problèmes.
Alors il faut être prudent, hein, pour beaucoup de physiciens, ses idées sont encore au stade de très, très flou
et il semble que le buzz autour de cette publication ait été largement exagéré.
Mais ce qu'il y a d'intéressant dans son idée c'est d'essayer de trouver une vraie justification théorique fondamentale aux équations de la théorie MOND
qui aujourd'hui sont juste des équations ad hoc qui ont été bricolées pour coller aux courbes de rotation.
Comme vous le voyez, la question de la matière noire a encore de quoi pas mal occuper les physiciens dans les prochaines années
que ça soit sur le plan de la théorie, des expériences ou bien des observations astrophysiques.
Alors avant de conclure, je voudrais quand même dire un tout petit mot sur l'énergie noire.
J'ai fait exprès de ne pas en parler mais si vous connaissez la matière noire, vous avez déjà certainement entendu parler
qu'en fait notre univers contiendrait en plus une immense quantité d'énergie (noire)
qui fait que la composition de l'univers serait plutôt 70 % d'énergie noire, 25 % de matière noire et 5 % de matière ordinaire.
Bref, que 95 % de la nature de l'univers nous serait inconnue.
Ouais mais non, j'aime pas trop cette manière de présenter les choses
qui laisse exagérément penser que l'énergie noire serait une espèce de substance qu'il faudrait détecter ou découvrir,
alors qu'en fait non, l'énergie noire et la matière noire, c'est pas du tout la même chose.
L'énergie noire, c'est avant tout un problème de théorie et si ça se trouve, c'est même pas un problème du tout.
Pour ce que ça intéresse, j'ai écrit un billet sur le sujet et je vous mettrais le lien dans la desription.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo, si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
si vous êtes déjà abonné, n'hésitez pas à cliquer sur la cloche, il parait que maintenant il faut dire de cliquer sur la cloche
donc cliquez sur la cloche, vous pouvez suivre les actus de la chaine sur Facebook et sur Twitter.
Et ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir sur Tipeee. Merci, à bientôt.